hey guys welcome to a session on
selenium interview questions
by simply learn in this video we will
look at most commonly asked questions in
the interview
and some guidelines on how to answer
them nowadays automation tool and
especially the selenium skills
is a very key requirement for an qa
engineer or even an automation engineer
jobs
so if you're on an outlook of automation
engineer or a qa engineer positions
i'm sure this question bank will
definitely help you prepare for your
interview
so this video consists of three parts
basically three different levels of set
of questions
one is the beginner level second is the
intermediate level and then
the advanced level questions and each
level has a set of 10 most probable
questions which you might be asked in
the interview so let's begin with the
beginner level questions
question 1 what are selenium suite
components
so selenium is a set of tools and
libraries to facilitate automation on
web applications
you already know this it is not a single
tool so what are those
components which are comprised in the
selenium so
selenium comes with four major
components the first one is the id
id happens to be the most simplest tool
in the whole suite of selenium it is
nothing but an integrated development
environment
which has a record and playback
functionality this was earlier available
as only firefox plugin
however you need to know that the new
version of selenium ide
is available as a chrome extension as
well as a firefox plugin
so that means you can either use any of
the browsers that is firefox or the
chrome for recording your test scripts
also you should also know that the new
ide comes with many new features and
now this new ide has become more
powerful than what was available earlier
so some of these new features are like
reusability of your test cases
it comes with a better debugger now and
most importantly it supports parallel
test execution
and how does it do that it has a utility
called selenium side runner that's about
selenium id
the next component is the selenium
remote control so selenium remote
control or popularly called as selenium
rc is used to write web application test
in different programming languages
it supports multiple programming
languages like java c
perl python ruby and php it is nothing
but it's a server
which interacts with your browser using
a simple
http get and post request for
communication
selenium rc is also called as selenium
1.0 version
or selenium core third component
selenium webdriver
it is a programming interface to run
your test cases
and webdriver was introduced by simon
stewart in
2006 and this was introduced to overcome
some of the limitations of selenium rc
so arses of architecture was very
complex
because it required an additional server
in its setup
and why was that additional server for
communicating with the browser
and what webdriver did was it removed
this dependency completely
webdriver interacts directly with the
browser and also
makes your test cases run much faster
than your rc
the last component the selenium grid a
very important tool
this is used to run multiple test
scripts on multiple machines
at the same time now with the selenium
webdriver you can only do sequential
execution
but in real time environment you always
have the need to run
test cases in a distributed environment
so this grid
allows parallel execution of tests on
different browsers as well as different
operating system
so the the design is in such a way that
commands are distributed on multiple
machines where you want to run the test
and they are executed simultaneously
this uses a simple hubbard node concept
where
hub controls the all execution of your
test cases on the nodes
and this is how we achieve parallel
execution and what is the major
advantage of having this grid
it is to reduce your overall test
execution type
question two what are the limitations of
selenium now like any other tool
selenium also has certain limitations so
when you are answering this question
you will also be expected to talk about
what is the
work around available for all these
limitations so let's look at them one by
one
no reliable tech support of course
selenium is an open source
so if you look at it you do not have
much technical support available
however there are loads of documentation
available
there are forums available which you can
refer to seleniumhq.org
is the website is your bible if you're
working with the selenium
and then there are there are a lot of
selenium google groups and the forums
which are available
for any kind of support so selenium has
been there for quite some time so it's
it's one of the most mature tool
available today so even though we do not
have a technical support available there
is
enough documentation available on the
internet
the second limitation selenium can test
only web application selenium is an open
source tool
that is designed to automate web-based
applications on different browsers
but it cannot handle windows gui
or non-html pop-ups in the application
now what is the workaround available
for that selenium provides a support for
integrating
other tools like auto it so auto it is a
tool for handling your
windows based activity selenium also
cannot automate mobile applications
but then what is available with that it
can integrate a tool called apm tool
which is a
mobile automation tool the third
limitation limited support for
image testing selenium is a de facto
tool for
functional web web application tests so
standard api
allows interacting only with the browser
and it's hard to test the
images based applications using selenium
what is the other tool available
securely is a very good tool to use for
image testing and this again
you can integrate securely with selenium
that's how you can achieve your
image testing through selenium but using
the security tool
no built-in reporting facility so
selenium does not have any reporting
capability as such of course it does
provide a very limited
reporting capability where some basic
reports are created
but definitely when you are working in a
framework you need a
better support for good reporting tools
so that way selenium supports some of
the tools like test
ng report ng and extend reports using
which
you can integrate these tools with
selenium and generate
beautiful reports limited test
management selenium does not provide any
test tool integration with test
management tools
may require knowledge of programming
languages so since selenium supports
multiple programming languages the
developer of the test automation
will require to have some basic
knowledge of any of the supported
programming language
why one in order to write your effective
automation scripts and of course because
selenium tool you want to use it at its
full potential
question three what are the testing
types supported by
selenium so selenium supports regression
testing
and functional testing these can be
called as a very high level categories
so what is regression testing regression
testing is a full
or partial selection of already executed
test cases
which are re-executed to ensure
your existing functionality does not
break so let's look at what are these
attributes of regression testing and why
we say that selenium
helps us in doing regression testing so
regression tests are
run every time a new fix has been
received
or a new feature has been deployed so
that is called as
retesting you can always select a full
suite
or select a test to test a fix or a
complete product so your selection can
be based on recently added features
a test area where most defects are there
or integration areas or even
end-to-end kind of tests you can also
prioritize your test cases
based on critical functionalities and
business
impact of this test cases according to
the priority
set so all this can be done using
selenium now what is the second category
of the testing which it supports
functional testing so functional testing
includes what your smoke does sanity
does say installed as
database test basically any kind of
functionality which you are going to
test
and if you look at the kind of steps
which are involved in that it involves
identification of your test inputs
expected outputs or the results the test
case logic itself and the assertions
so a typical flow will be you identify
your test inputs first then you derive
your test outcomes or the expected
outputs you design
and execute your test cases and then
assert on the expected versus
actual outcomes question four what are
selenium 2.0 and three daughter versions
so selenium was introduced by a
gentleman called jason huggins way back
in 2004 and that was selenium version
since then this store has gone through
multiple changes to make it
better and better so if selenium two dot
version
had a major change it took a leap
forward in terms of browser automation
the selenium rc the remote control had a
disadvantage
of having the need of an additional
server
to talk to the web browsers and because
of this the text execution was much
slower
and the com architecture itself became
very complex so if you look at
this selenium 2 it had two components a
successor to rc
and the rc itself which is called as
your core
so this successor was nothing but your
web driver api
so web driver apis made it easier to
write your automation scripts for any
browser
by simply using a suitable driver for
any browser which you want to run the
tests on
apart from these two components the
selenium 2.0 version
also had the id and the grid components
so in summary if you look at it selenium
2.0 version has an ide
it has selenium rc which was on its way
of deprecation
webdriver api which was just introduced
in there
a very very earlier version of webdriver
api and the
grid so what is selenium 3.0 consists so
selenium 3.0
rc was completely eliminated now because
in 2.0 it was already on its path of
deprecation
and webdriver replaced rc completely so
if you look at the components of 3.0 we
have ide
we have a web driver and grid as the
major components
so now with this introduction of web
driver a full-fledged web driver
selenium became the most powerful tool
for web application
automation question five a very
important question what is same origin
policy
and how was it handled now same origin
policy is a security id feature so it is
a very important concept
in web application security model and
what is this
according to this policy a web browser
allows
scripts from one web page to access the
contents
of another web page provided both these
pages
are on the same origin now what does
origin mean
origin is nothing but a combination of
your url schema
the host number and the port number it's
basically your
domain now if a such question is asked
how are you going to explain it
so let's say you have a javascript
program which runs in a certain domain
say google.com okay so this program can
access
all the programs which are from the same
origin now origin here is what
google.com
so for example you can access other
pages like your google drive your google
email or your google calendar
however now if you use the same
javascript
right so if you use the same script from
the google.com
to access another page or an element in
a different domain
say yahoo.com then the security model of
the web application
itself prohibits you to do so so what
happens because of that is you are
limited with access only to those
elements and pages
which are in the same domain but now
look at a case that
you want to run your test on multiple
servers and
you might also want to access multiple
domain so due to the same origin policy
you will not be able to
do so and this became a major limitation
with a very early selenium tool so how
was this handled so
this got handled by paul heman who
created the selenium remote control
so he created the selenium remote
control server to trick the browser
in believing that the selenium core and
the web application
under test actually came from the same
domain and this is how the same origin
policy was handled
and this selenium rc which is selenium
remote control became the version one of
selenium question six what is celine
and how is it classified selenium
commands for selenium ide
are often called as selenis they are a
set of commands that run your test
and sequence of this command is called
as a test script
now these commands are categorized into
three major categories
one is the action command now action
commands are the commands that generally
manipulate the state of your application
for example they can do things like
click on this link or select a
particular option open a url
type certain text into an input box
click or double click on any web element
and so on so these are called as action
commands the second set of commands is
the accessors
now accessors examine the state of the
application
and store the results in a variable so
it basically allows the user to store
certain values to a user defined
variable
for example if i want to store the page
title of a web page
i can do that by defining a user defined
variable and then
these stored values can be later used to
create your assertions or verifications
in your test
now few examples of such commands are
you can just use a store story
or a store text store title or a store
value so these are some of the accessor
commands
the third category is the assertions
assertions are like your accesses
but they verify the state of your
application and conforms to
what is expected so basically it is a
comparison of your actual versus
expected results there are two types of
assertions available
one is the softer sessions and the
harder sessions an example of your soft
assertion can be
verify title wherein you verify the
title check whether
the expected and the actual outcomes are
the same and continue with your test
case now whereas in hard assertion is
you do an assert title using the command
assert title and if at all the assertion
fails the test case stops from
executing question 7 mention the types
of web locator what is web locator a
locator is a command
that tells the selenium which ui element
you want to operate on
selenium uses locators to find and match
the elements
of your web page which it needs to
interact with and there are around
eight locating techniques in selenium
the first one is by id
now this is the most common way of
locating elements
why since the ids are supposed to be
unique for each element
the ids can also be dynamic in nature so
you can identify
them by inspecting the attributes of the
web element
so let's look at an example so if we go
to a facebook
right so if you go to the facebook and
say if i want to identify this element
email so if you look at this highlighted
text here it has a unique id
which is email so if i am going to
operate on this particular element email
i can directly use the id locating
technique
link text and the partial link text so
this type of locator applies
only to the hyperlink text so we access
the link
by using this locator which needs the
hyperlink text to be provided
so for link text you can give a complete
text in the link text
or let's let's look at an example of
that so let's if you go to say one of
the e-commerce site which is
say amazon dot in and say you want to
click on this today's deal link so if
you look here in amazon.com there are a
lot of hyperlinks available here and if
an example if you have to take an
example say we want to click on the
today's tale
now if you inspect this element you will
see that it has an
anchor tag a it has an associated href
link here and also it has a text which
says today's deal
right which is what is displayed on your
web page now similarly there is also a
link available here called
customer service so if you inspect that
customer service it also has something
similar what the today's deal had
it has an anchor tab it has an href link
and
it has a long text which says customer
service which is what is displayed
now if you have to use your web locator
which is a linked text you need to
provide the complete text which is
displayed on your web page
and there is another way of using the
link text by saying partial
link text where you can just give a
partial text
which can be matched against the
complete text of your
link and this is how you can use your
partial link text or the
link text the next id is by name so
locating elements by name is very
similar to locating by id
just that your attribute instead of
using an id you're going to use
name in this case now if you look at the
same example of say facebook
we identified this email element using
its id you can
also locate the same element by using
the name
attribute which is also unique in this
case which has a value called email
tag name that's the next identifier so
locate element using tag name of the
element now say if you want to identify
all the elements on your web page which
are
of type button so that you can do by
using the tag name as button there
for example again on your facebook page
i know that there is a single button
here
which is of type button and which has a
tag as button
and this is the only button which is
available on this page so if i want to
access this particular element
i can simply use a locator technique
called tag
which is button in this case next
locator class name so locate an element
using its class name attribute
so you can use this identifier only if
you find
that a class name is unique for a web
element which you want to work with
class names are sometimes unique a web
element can also have multiple class
name or even you will find some elements
which has no class name
so depending on what is available in the
attributes you can
use this class name for identification
so example
the shown on your screen here where it
says find element by class name
input text basically this is going to
list out all
elements on your web page which has a
class name called
input text the next identifier is by
xpath
now xpath is a language used when
locating
xml nodes what is xml extendable markup
language
it can access almost any element even
those without any class names or
names or even id attributes so whenever
you do not find a unique attribute for
id
name or class name you can construct an
expat to create an unique identifier for
that particular element
now for example on this facebook page if
you observe here there is a
label here called create an account so
if you inspect this particular label
it has no attributes other than a tag
called spam so if you want to identify
this particular element and say display
it
this is one of the ways to do it is
through xpath
css selector so css selector are string
patterns
used to identify an element based on the
combination
of either the html tag id class or any
other attributes
locating by css selector is little more
complicated
than any of the previous method however
the advantage is
css selectors work much faster than the
xpath
the performance of your test scripts is
much better when you use css selector
than any other locating technique
now again as an example if you see the
facebook again
you can identify the same email here
right
i used an id here or a name attribute
here to identify it
so assume that if you did not have any
of those things or if you want to use a
css selector here you can still do that
by using this syntax this is how you use
the css selector to identify an element
question 8 what are the types of weights
supported by
webdriver now before even you answer
this question
you should know why do we need weights
in selenium
weights play a very important role in
executing test cases
most of the web applications are
developed using using
ajax and javascripts so when a page is
loaded by the browser
the elements which you want to interact
may load at a different time intervals
not only this makes it difficult to
identify the elements but
also if the element is not located it
will start throwing
element not visible exception and how do
we resolve this by using the weights
so there are three different kind of
weights available in selling it first
one is the implicit weight
the implicit weight tells the browser or
your web driver
to wait for a certain amount of time
before it can throw
no such element exception now the
default setting is zero for this
once we set a time what web web driver
does it it will wait
for that time so if you have mentioned
10 seconds it will wait for 10 seconds
until it finds the element and even in
the 10 seconds it is unable to find that
element only after that it throws an
exception
now what is the syntax of this implicit
weight is
this is the syntax of this where you use
driver.manage timeouts
implicit weight and there is a timeout
value say 10 seconds
and the unit whether it's in minutes
seconds or milliseconds is what you can
mention
implicit weight is applied globally to
all the elements which means
it is available for all the web elements
throughout the driver instance
implicit weight is defined only once and
it will remain
same throughout the driver object
instance now let's see what explicit
weight is
so explicit weight is used to tell the
web driver to wait
for certain conditions before throwing
an
element not visible exception it is
defined to wait for certain
expected conditions only now these
expected conditions can check
whether the element is displayed on the
web page or not or can be clicked or not
so any kind of conditions you can
mention there so these are called as
conditional weights and
they are applied on a web element on a
single web element
unlike the implicit weight which was
kind of applied globally to all elements
it is definitely recommended to use this
explicit weights when your elements are
taking longer time to load and also for
verifying the property of the elements
like say visibility of the element
located
element to be click applicable or
element to be selected
then we have fluent width now fluid
weight is used to tell the web driver to
wait for a condition
that is very similar to the explicit
weight as well as
a frequency with which we want to keep
checking the condition
before throwing the not visible
exception so fluent weight is used to
define
the maximum amount of time you want the
web driver to wait
for a condition then if you look in the
syntax then there is polling
every second so polling every and you
give a timeout this could be like five
seconds so start
pulling to see whether the web element
is available or not say once in three
seconds once in four seconds depending
on
your use case and then dot ignoring so
you can also try to ignore specific type
of exceptions while waiting now for
example such as no such element
exception which is sometimes thrown when
searching for an element on page so you
can mention even that here so fluid
weight takes two parameters one is the
timeout value
and the pulling frequency so when we
have web elements which sometimes
are visible after few seconds or
sometimes it takes more time than usual
like we have ajax applications as an
example we can set a default polling
period
based on our requirement and then as i
said you can also ignore some of the
exceptions by pulling this
element question nine mention the types
of navigation commands
available in selenium so webdriver
provides a basic
browser navigation commands that allows
the browser to move forward backward
refresh and using the browser history
and this is done
using some of the driver.navigate
methods right so these are some of the
commonly used navigation methods
first one is navigate to so this method
loads a new web page in the existing
browser window
and it accepts string as a parameter and
returns nothing
so it's a void so the url you mentioned
here needs to be a fully formed url
driver.navigate.refresh so this method
refreshes or reloads the current web
page in the existing browser window
it neither accepts anything so there is
no value passed or it returns
nothing forward so this method enables
the web browser to click on the forward
button in the existing
browser window again this has this has
no arguments to be passed or
it returns nothing driver.navigate.back
so this method enables the web browser
to click on the back button in the
existing browser window
again this returns nothing nor it needs
any argument
question 10 what is the major difference
between driver.close and driver.quitter
so this is again a very important
question
and pretty confusing also sometimes so
selenium webdriver provides two methods
for closing the browser window one is
browser.close
and the other one is the browser.quit so
you might think
to use them interchangeably and that's
that's what everybody thinks that both
anyway does the same function so it can
be used however it is not so
both are two different methods now
driver.close command is used to close
the
current browser window which is having
the focus and in case if there is a only
single browser window open then calling
this driver.close actually quits the
complete browser session
now it is used when you're working with
say multiple browser tabs or windows and
you want to just close
one of them which is in focus in the
test whereas the driver.quit
is used to quit the complete browser
session
along with all its associated windows
tabs pop-ups and everything
so when do you use browser.quit it is
best to use use browser.quit or sorry
driver.quit
when you no longer want to interact with
the driver object along with
all its associated windows tabs and
pop-ups generally it is one of the last
statements of your automation scripts so
in case you are like working with
selenium with test ng or g j unit we
usually call this driver dot quit in the
after switch that is at
after suite method of our test suite
thus by by doing that we close
the complete browser session at the end
of the test fit execution
now let's look at some intermediate
level questions
question 11 how to type in an input box
using
selenium so selenium provides a method
or a command you can say to insert value
into
any of the input box and this command is
called as a send keys command
so send keys is a method available in a
web element
now this is how you use the send keys so
here is an example so first
you need to find the element using any
of the eight locating techniques
and once you find the element in this
case which is an email field
you need to call a method called send
keys send keys takes an argument which
is of type
string so you can pass the value which
you want to pass to the web element so
in this case you will be passing a
gmail id or any id which will be your
email id here
and then similarly you do it for your
password field
so first you find the element password
and then you send the password using
send case this is a very simple method
to use question 12
how to click on a hyperlink in selenium
so whenever you're testing an e-commerce
application you are going to find
lot of hyperlinks on your web pages
which you will obviously need to test
now selenium
provides two locating techniques using
which you can identify this
hyperlinks and using these is what you
need to
operate on the hyperlinks on your web
pages so one is using
link text and other one is using
partially text so using link text
you give a complete text in the link
text
that is if you look at in your
e-commerce site let's say amazon dot in
let's
let's go to that website and see what it
means so in the amazon dot in if you
look at
some of these hyperlink text called
today's deals or amazon pay or sell or
customer service
if you inspect this element you will see
that
this is associated with a link text
which is called as today's team along
with this
href and of course an anchor tag so one
way of identifying this link is to use
this complete text which is today's t
also there is another way by using
partial link text for say example you
have a link text which is pretty
long and you do not want to use this
complete text
instead you can use the locating
technique called partial link text
and give a partial text from that in
this example
instead of giving the complete customer
service here you can just say
use a customer or you can just use
service as your text
only thing whatever will be required
here is this has to be unique on this
page
there shouldn't be two elements which
would have this text which you are going
to
use so let's quickly see this in action
how do we
use this link text and partial link text
now we will be using the same example of
amazon.com so my use cases
first i will click on this today's deal
and after a sleep of two or three
seconds i will also click on customer
service
and i am going to achieve this one by
using link text so if you see in this
program
so i have this method written which is
going to click on today's tale
and this is using a locating technique
link text and then
i also have another method here by using
partial link text
i'm going to be clicking on the customer
service
link right so let's see how this works
so i'll just go ahead and execute this
so this launches the amazon dot in and
the first thing what we are doing is it
is going to click on today's still
all right that is done and then it will
click on the customer service link
right so this is how you can achieve
clicking on the
hyperlinks in your web applications
question 13
how to scroll down a page using
javascript
this is a very important question and
usually this gets asked quite often in
the interview
you should know that you can run java
scripts through selenium and selenium
provides a way to do this
selenium provides an interface called
javascript
executor javascript executor and this
helps in executing
any kind of javascripts through the
selenium webdriver so this javascript
executor it has
basically two methods one is execute
script and the other one is execute its
async script to run the javascript on
the selected window or on your current
page
but why do you need this right so if if
you are answering this question
you should also have a background that
why at all this is required because
sometimes you need to perform certain
functions which
cannot be done using the locators what
has been provided
like say scrolling down the web page
itself also sometimes you will see that
you are unable to even identify some web
elements using all the
locating techniques which is made
available by selenium so in such
situations what you can do is you can
directly write a javascript
and execute it using this javascript
executor
and if you look at it the syntax is
something like this so it says
javascript executor
js is equal to javascript executor and
driver now if you look at this
javascript executor is an interface that
means you cannot create an object of it
and hence
you type cast it to your driver object
now how do you do this
now first thing what you do is you
launch your web application
on whatever web application is under
test and then
on that current window you call this
particular
execute script method using the
javascript executor
and then you can perform any functions
here in this example we are seeing a
function which is crawling down
vertically so this function takes an
attributes or arguments like x
coordinate and the y coordinate
now in this example our x coordinate is
zero and y coordinate is one thousand
that means when this command gets
executed the page is going to
get scrolled down vertically by thousand
pixels
so why don't we just see this in action
so let's go to
another program here called the
scrolling tester java so basically what
i'm doing here is i'm going to be
logging into amazon.com
and then i will show you how to scroll
down by 600 pixels so it's a very very
simple code to write
you launch your application then you
create your object of javascript
executor
right actually you type caster to the
driver and then you just use an execute
script command
or a method this you see is your actual
script which gets executed
which says windows dot scroll by 0 comma
600
which is x coordinate and y coordinate
let's go ahead and execute this
so when amazon.in is launched and you
should see the screen scrolling down
yes there we go so it just scroll down
by few pixels
and that is 600 pixels what we mentioned
see i could scroll back again
and that is how you can achieve
scrolling functions and when do you
usually use this
say if you have a very long web page and
you want to go and identify or do some
operations on the web element which is
probably available to you towards the
end of the page
and that is when you can use some of the
scrolling functions
question 14 how to assert the title of a
web page
selenium web driver provides web driver
methods and one such method
is called get title so what get title
does is it fetches the title of the
current page
how to use this command get titles
returns a string
which is nothing but your title of your
page that means you need a string
variable
in which you can store this value so
what you do is you define a string
variable like it is defined in this
example to store your
title and then you execute this command
driver.gettitle which is going to fetch
the title and that value gets stored in
your
actual title once you get the title you
can do any operations with that
in this case what we are doing is we are
trying to verify the title
there are two ways which you can verify
that one is using an if else statement
where you compare your actual title with
the expected title or
alternately you can also use assert
statements here
right so selenium provides a search
statement so using assert
you can validate whether your title of
the web page is as expected
question 15 how to mouse over over an
element
in automation many times it is required
to perform some action on the element
which gets visible only on the mouse
hovering on those elements
now in selenium action is a class which
we can
use to achieve this functionality so
action is defined in a package called as
selenium.interactions
this has a set of apis to emulate
complex user gestures
it helps in building the patterns of
action
and then perform that action on a web
element now this action class provides a
rich set of apis
like so for mouse events and even the
keyboard events so say for to perform
any kind of mouse event
it provides a method called move to
element now in this example what you do
is you
initiate an object of mouse class and
then use this move to element method
and what it does is the element is
scrolled into the view
first even before the move operations
happen so you could have multiple
actions like
here in this example we are just using
move to element but also you can if you
want to do a drag and drop observation
you can still have that
so in such case where you have multiple
actions like a drag and drop
then you use a method called build along
with this
so you say actions dot move to element
dot build and then dot perform
so dot build method is called before the
perform method and what it does is it
generates the composite
actions which has all those multiple
actions which you want to perform on a
web element
then after the building action is done
you call a perform method which actually
performs that action on your web element
and this is how
the move to element method of the action
class is used
why don't we just see that in action
let's say let's go to our
eclipse here and i have a mouse hover
test written here
so let's say we go to amazon dot website
so in the amazon
uh if you go to the shop by category you
see that so the moment i mouse over it
it is going to give me this drop down
list so for me to select any element
from this
my first action on this web page should
be
to go and just hover my mouse over this
web element
called shop by category and that's
exactly i'm going to achieve
through my automation now here in my
methods here what i have written
i have said okay first launch your
website which is amazon.n
and then i'm finding that element which
is shop by category using an xpath so
you could use any available locating
technique to find the element first
and then i instantiate an object of
actions and then
simply i'm doing is i'm using the method
move to element
and then i'm just going to say perform
that means my mouse would actually get
moved or hovered onto that particular
element okay so let's see this in action
so i'll just
execute this test case okay so amazon
dot is launched and now we should see
yeah the mouse actually moved to shop by
category and because of
that we got this drop down list so and
this is how you can
achieve your mouse over functionality
question 16 how to retrieve the css
properties of an
element now css is nothing but cascading
style sheets
it's a style sheet language used for
describing the presentation of a
document written in your markup language
it basically describes your html
elements as how they need to be
displayed on the screen it's basically
the look and feel like your font size
the width height color and so on so it
provides a special and easy way
to specify various properties of the
element now why do we need this
we need to use a special method called
get css value to retrieve such chs
properties of web element why because we
already have a method called get
attribute
which can retrieve the value of the
attributes right however
the get attribute method can only
retrieve
those properties where the attribute and
its value are mentioned in your dom
and hence all this font size color
cannot be retrieved through the get
attribute method
and that is why we use the get css value
so basically it works like your get
method
and you need to provide the attribute
which you want to fetch using the get
css value so in this example what we are
trying to do is
we have a web element called the email
id
and of that we are trying to fetch the
font size
so let's again check this in action so
if i go to my web page here
let's close this so if i go to my
facebook and
if i inspect this particular element
which is the email id
and on the right if you see there are
multiple
other attributes of that element you see
right so you see the background color
you see the color here then you
see something called as font size and
say for example we want to
retrieve the font size of this
particular web element and you will also
see on the left
where you are seeing the dom here you do
not see that font size anywhere as an
attribute and its value here
and that is why i cannot use the get
attribute method to retrieve it now
instead of that what i am going to do is
i am going to use the get css value
and use this font size for that so let's
go to my eclipse
i have a method written here where i log
into the facebook
and then i'm going to first find that
element which is by id
and i'm going to retrieve the css value
and i'm just simply printing it on the
console
so if i execute this so it's going to
launch the facebook
and since i'm not going to do anything
on the facebook web page as such let's
go to my console here
because this is where i'm expecting the
output so here it has given me the
output in the console saying
12px which is nothing but your actual
font says what you see here in your
html page right and this is how you can
extract your css properties of any web
element on your
web page question 17 what is page object
model
popularly known as pom page object model
is a design pattern that
helps create object repositories for web
elements
so writing selenium test cases without
say using any patterns
may lead to code duplicacy and also the
code becomes
unmaintainable after some time and say
if you have web element locators which
changes over time
then you will have to go through the
entire code base to make all the
required changes
so under this model for each web page in
the application there should be a
corresponding
page class and this page class will have
all the web elements of the web page
and also it contains the page methods
which perform
operations on the web elements and the
verification steps required in your test
cases are the separate test cases
they are not combined in the same class
now the tests that use the methods of
this page object class
whenever they need to interact with the
ui of that page the benefit here is if
the page ui changes that the tests
need not be changed only the code within
this page object class needs to be
changed that is you go and just change
the web elements or the locators of the
web elements only in one place which is
your
page class and not in any of your test
classes or not test classes
so how does this form help so it makes
the code more readable
maintainable and reusable so there are
two ways you can implement a bomb
or a page object model one is done using
the page factory which is offered by
selenium and then you can also
achieve a page object model without
using the page factory
using directly the objects and the
classes question 18
can capture be automated this is again
a very favorite question of the
interview captcha is a security feature
that prevents
bots and automated programs from
accessing sensitive information
yes and captcha cannot be automated you
will see that there are many
applications today who have captcha
why because it's a security feature it
is a concept to differentiate between
human and computers
the idea of captcha itself is to prevent
any automated process
or a robotic process to do any kind of
actions
and say if you're going to automate it
then the entire idea of having the
captcha is lost
so you should never attempt to automate
it but then what do you how can you
handle this then
one either you can ask your developers
to disable it in the test environment
so that you can test the whole
application without having to hit on
this captcha
other way of doing is you can use static
data for your captcha
so that you can hard code that value in
your test for the time being
and then since your application has
captcha as one of its functionality if
you really need to test that
you can just test that separately as a
manual testing itself but not
automated question 19 how does selenium
handle windows based pop-up
selenium is an automation tool for
automating web applications
it cannot handle windows based
application however
we can use tools like auto it and robot
class
along with selenium to handle such
pop-ups so what are these
tools robot class is a java class which
along with selenium
can simulate your keyboard and mouse
events
it also helps in upload and download of
files and also to manage the pop-ups
so wherever you have a requirement of
doing a file upload operation
in which if your native dialog box opens
up
then one of the way to handle it is
using robot class
other tool which is available for us is
the auto it tool
it is a freeware and what it does is it
uses a combination of your mouse
movement keystrokes and window control
manipulation to automate any such task
which is not possible by selenium web
drives and again this auto it tool can
be integrated with selenium and thus you
can achieve the automation of
native window based pop-ups question 20
how to take screenshots in webdriver
take screenshot
interface can be used to take
screenshots and webdriver
so selenium provides us this interface
for managing our screenshot operations
now screenshots are desirable for bug
analysis so selenium can automatically
take the screenshots during your
execution you know that it is very
important to take screenshots when we
execute the test scripts
say if we have a huge number of test
scripts running
and if some of the test case fail we
need to check why this test case failed
so using the screenshot functionality it
helps us
debug and identify the problem by
looking at the screenshots
so webdriver has this built-in
functionality to take the screenshot
across the page and it's pretty easy to
use
take screenshot interface is used to
capture the screenshot during the
execution now this
interface has a method called grid get
screenshot as
which captures a screenshot and it also
stores
in a location specified by us so let's
take an example
of our facebook page and say we fail a
particular test case on the facebook
application
and then let's see how we take a
screenshot at that particular moment
when the test case fails
so let's go to the facebook page first
and let's understand the use case
so in this facebook page say if i am
signing up on this page
i need to enter all this field now as a
part of demo
what i will do is i just enter the first
name and the surname and i will click on
the sign up button with this test case
it should basically
not sign me up rather it should give me
some error saying that you need to enter
all the fees
and at that minute we are going to take
a screenshot okay so that's our use case
so let's see how do we achieve that
so if i go to my eclipse and let's say
we go to my screenshot test.java
i have a method written here so and
these are the operations which i just
described which i am doing it here so i
am going to just
send keys my first name to the first
name field second name into the third
name field
and then i am just going to click on the
sign up button now there are few things
required
for us to do before we use the take
screenshot interface along with its
method which is the get screen shortest
so i said that this method stores
the screenshot taken in a file so that
means i need to provide it a file name
and also a location where it needs to be
placed so in our demo here in this test
class what i have done is i have created
a folder called screenshot
in the same project directory and then i
am giving it a file name
called fblogin.png so that means after
the screenshot is taken
it is saved in a file called fblogin.png
and then
it is stored in the location screenshot
folder and these are the simple file
operations of java which i use
to achieve this so let's execute this
and see how this happens so right now i
have this screenshot folder and it's an
empty folder
so after the execution i'm expecting
that this particular file would get
created so let's see that in action so
i'll go ahead and execute this java
program
okay so we have launched the
facebook.com and then
i entered the my first name second name
and it has also clicked on signup after
which it has given all this red marks
here
and now this is what i'm expecting in
the screenshot
so let's go back to our eclipse i will
refresh this folder so i'll say right
click and refresh
okay i have this file created so let's
open this file and see
right so do you see this this whole
image has been captured so now as a
tester
if at all this test case fails for me i
can always open this png file and see
what actually happened and i can debug
my test case
so this is how you use screenshot
functionality in
selenium level questions question 21 can
you type in a text box
without using send keys so you need an
alternative way
to use instead of using the send keys
function and one such
alternative is using javascript executor
so selenium provides an interface called
javascript executor
and this helps in executing any
javascripts through your
selenium webdriver so you can do any
kind of function
using this javascript and one of the
functions which we can do is the send
keys kind of a function
now how to replicate a send keys
function using javascript so let's see
an
example here now since this javascript
executor is an interface
you cannot create an object of this
interface so what you do you type casted
to your
driver object the way it is done here in
this example
and then you use document dot
get element id to get the actual element
on which you're going to perform the
operations of sending the keys
now what is this document so it is an
object
right so this document it's an object
that represents your html document
which is displayed in that window and
this document object has various
properties that refer to
other object which allows you the access
to modify
any of your document content so the
argument which you're passing through
the java execute script is nothing but
your javascript now this javascript uses
the document
object to identify your element and then
send the value which you need to send to
that element
so let's see this in action as how it
works so let me show you a small program
here
all right so i have a method here
wherein
i'm trying to identify the email field
of your facebook page
so if this is your facebook application
this is my email field
and instead of using send keys here i'm
going to pass a email value to this
and how am i doing that using a
javascript executor
right so if i execute this particular
java program
it is exactly going to do the same
function what
i would do otherwise using the send case
so let's execute this and see if
i can see my user's id email in the
facebook application so the facebook
application is launched and there we go
so we this is the value which i have
sent using my javascript
okay so this is how you can use a
javascript executor
to replicate a send keys method question
22
how to select a value from your drop
down list in the selenium webdriver
so select class is a selenium webdriver
it is used for selecting
and deselecting options in your drop
down list
the objects of select type can be
initialized by passing the drop down web
element
as a parameter to its constructor like
in this example i am saying select
drop down equal to new select of test
drop so test drop is nothing but the web
element which i have identified
using any locating techniques after you
create the select object
then you have three different methods
available for
actually selecting your methods and what
are these methods
one is select by index now the index
starts with zero in the list
so you can select any element from your
list using the
index side and then the second one is
select by values
so this is used to select an option
based on its value
attribute select by visible text so this
is an option wherein
you can select a particular list item or
an
option based on the text displayed in
the option so that means whatever text
you can see
on your drop down list is what you will
use it to identify that particular
element
so let's see the demo for this so i have
again a same facebook application which
i have considered here for demo
so if you go to our facebook application
first you know that there is a drop down
menu here
now this drop down is for selecting your
birthdate
this has a day values which you can
select the month values
right and the year now what i have done
in my code is
first thing is i've identified all these
drop down boxes
using one of i'm using mostly the id
locating technique here so you can use
any of your choice
so once i identify the element i created
the select object class
for each of this and i pass that web
element to the constructor of the select
class
so now my select element or the object
is ready to use
so my next step what i need to do is i
need to go and select the actual dates
now in this use case what i want is i
want to select a date which is 10th june
2005.
that means on my select drop down of the
day i should be able to select
the day 10 now this i am achieving by
using
select by value and then i am selecting
the bun
month based on the index which is the
index in this case is 6
which will select the june for me and
then the third one i'm trying to select
it by visible text
wherein i am selecting the year 2000 y
so when i execute this program
let's see how the date selection happens
okay
there we go so it selected the 10 the
day 10 the june month and the 2005
so this is how you use select objects in
selenium question 23
what does the switch to command do so
switch to command is used to switch
between windows frames or even the alert
pop-ups within your
application right so there are multiple
things which you can do with switch to
now sometimes in your web application
say when you click on a button
it opens up a completely new browser
window or you will also see
it opens up another tab in your browser
say for example let's look at one of
this application which i have
let me go to my browser and say
i launch hdfcbank.com
all right so this is my application say
which you want to test now when you
launch
this first thing is i see this
advertisement pop-up which comes up
which is right now an unwanted pop-up so
right now i'll just close this
and now if i want to enter this hdfc
bank application first i need to do a
login so if i click on this login button
see there is a new window which opens up
and i need to go and operate into this
window so for any further operations i
want to do it on this web page i need to
switch to this window
and then say i want to click on continue
to netbanking
and then continue with my use case so
now in this application there are two
windows open
one is your base window from where we
actually logged in and after i clicked
on the login there is a new window
opened up
right so this is where your switch to
command will help us
to switching to this particular window
to do any of the operations
on this web elements present on this
window okay now let's see how do we
actually do this
so in order to do this first you need to
get the handle of the window
by using a command called driver dot
get window handle all right so now when
you use driver dot get window handle
what you get is a unique alphanumeric
value which is an
identifier for that window and once you
get this you use a command called
driver.switch2
dot window and you pass that handle
which you have fetched previously
and this command will actually switch to
the current window which is in your
focus
now you will also come across a case
where there are multiple windows open
right now the example what we saw we
just had a single window but say if you
whenever you launch an application say
there are multiple windows which are
open so in such case you can use
something called as get windows
handles right now get windows handles
what it does it picks up
all the active windows at that point of
a time and using a for loop
you can read into every handle and then
you do your operations specific to your
window handles
also there is another way wherein you
can switch back to your parent window
so if ever you want to switch back to
your parent window you have to use the
same command driver.switch2 and
the handle what you need to provide here
is your parent handle all right so this
is about windows
then i also said switch 2 can be used
for your frames
so what are frames frames are usually
used to divide your web application or
your web page
or the on the same domain into various
different windows or sections
right so for us to operate on elements
which are in different frames we need to
first switch to a particular frame and
then
use the web elements on that so the same
command will be using
now instead of window here i would say
driver dot switch to
dot free similarly even the alert popups
can be handled
using the same command so in the case of
alert what you need to do is you have to
say driver dot switch to
dot question 20 how to upload a file in
selenium web driver
right a very important concept in
selenium webdriver we know that selenium
webdriver
is designed for automating web
application
right and file upload is a very common
scenario which we get with every web
application which we are working with
now there are two ways to do a file
window file upload operation
one is using the send keys which is the
simplest method
and the other way is using robot class
now there are certain prereqs required
for you to work with the send keys
option now if you are using the send
keys option
what you basically need to do is you
need to type in the complete
path of the file along with the file
name right in the file select
input field now this element where
you're going to enter your file name
should have certain attributes one of
the attribute is it should
have the tag as input right and also it
should have an attribute called type
which should have a value of file only
then
it is possible for you to enter a file
name and upload the file okay that is by
using the
send keys method then the other way is
using robot now when
when is that we need to use robot where
whenever you have an application and in
your application
usually for your file upload you have a
button which says
upload a file and when you click on that
it opens a new window
and this window is your windows explorer
window or a finder window depending on
what operating system you're working and
these are the native windows
and we know that selenium webdriver
directly cannot handle the
native applications so in such case the
robot class
helps us in managing these native
windows
so what happens in the robot classes it
helps you manage your file upload
dialog box by simulating all the actions
required for selecting a particular file
from your dialog box
and then you go and upload them all
right so this is the example of using
the
send keys question 25 how to set
browser window size in web driver so you
can either maximize the window or
set it to a certain value now to do this
you use
a simple functions provided by
driver.manage
one of the functions using driver.manage
is
driver.manage
driver.manage.window.maximize
now this command maximizes the current
window
and say you want to set a particular
window size rather than maximizing it
and then for that you have a command
called
dot window driver.manage.window.org set
size now this set size
takes an argument of the type dimension
class
so this is basically when you create a
dimension class you are passing the size
of the window which you want to
create here right so we use the
dimension class define the new
dimensions
of the window and then pass the object
of this dimensions to the
set size method this is one way of doing
it we also saw that using javascript
executor we can do
any kind of functionality so if you want
to minimize
or maximize or set a different size to
your browser windows this can
also be done using a javascript okay
let's see a quick demo
on how do we use this driver.manage dot
set size or the maximize command so
let's go to my eclipse here
so i have this method written here so i
have two methods
one method where i'm saying i'm going to
maximize the window this particular
command
is where i'm am saying
driver.manage.window.maximise and i'm
launching a facebook application so
first let's
run this particular method and see how
our browser window behaves
so i'll just say execute this
so now you will see the whole window
your browser window is in maximized mode
so now from here i'm going to execute
the other set of
lines here using which i'm going to set
a certain size
now i'll just comment out these two
lines and
then these are the two commands which i
am going to use
right so here what i have done is i have
defined
an object of the class dimension and i
have used 600 600 which is the size of
the window which i want it to be
and then using the set size i am passing
this dimension
object to the set size method now let's
see how do we
look at this browser window now did you
see that so it was at a certain size and
it just shrunk
it shrunk because i have used a smaller
size window
question 26 when do we use find element
and find elements now find element you
can use this command to access
any single element on your page and what
does it return it returns an object of
the first matching element of the
specified locator
and this is the most common command what
we use for working with every web
element
on the web page what is find elements
find elements is used to return
a list of web elements right so each
element
which it identifies is indexed with the
number starting from 0. it's just like
an
array i'll show you an example of that
so that you can understand it better so
let's go to my eclipse here
right so if you look at this
locators.java i have
different elements which i have
identified using different locating
techniques
right so for that i use a simple command
called find element
now say i have a use case right wherein
i want to fetch all the web elements who
have a class name
starting with the text input let's see
what that is so if i go to my facebook
application
if i try to inspect this say first name
right so i'll say inspect element now
here if you see
this particular web element has a class
name starting with
text called as input text likewise there
are many elements here
like even the surname if you look at it
it has a class name starting with input
text
okay so if i have a use case like that
where i want
all the web elements on the facebook
page who have the class name starting
with
the text input if i have to do that that
is when i
say i am going to use the driver.find
elements
so i say driver dot find elements i give
an x path
which is going to pick up all those
elements which has the class name
starting with input
this is my x path expression once i get
all the elements what am i doing i am
going to store it in a list
array once i have all these elements
created it's in an array
i'm just going to traverse through the
array using an enhanced for loop
so in this program in this test case i'm
just picking each and every element
and printing the attribute id of each
element
so if i execute this now we should see
all the elements
on the facebook page which has the class
name
starting with input and we should see
all the ids of that
so this is what we are getting so you
are around getting 9 to 10 elements it
has picked up
and all of them have the class name
starting with input
and these are their different ids
question 27
what is pause on exception in selenium
id
so pause on exception is a new feature
of selenium ide
it is one of the brilliant debugger
function which this new selenium id
provides us what it does is it enables
us or
when this particular option is enabled
the execution of your test
pauses if at all there is any exception
which
occurs in your test scripts and because
of this what you can do is you can go
and handle that error
by say changing your command in the
script and then continue your test
execution so this helps in debugging
your code pretty well so whenever there
is an exception
say for example and web element which
you are trying to identify
has a wrong identifier or it changes on
your web page
then you can correct that command which
caused the exception
and then resume the test execution from
that point onwards
so let's look at a simple use case and
see how exactly this works
so for example let's go to my browser
here
okay so i have a simple use case here
where i want to login into facebook
using my email id and password and what
i have done is i have created a script
or recorded a script using my selenium
id
so these are all the steps which it has
wherein it logs into the facebook
account then it clicks on the email
field
enters the email this is my value which
i'm passing clicks on the password field
enters the password and then clicks on
the login button now this is
a clean test script and all my web
elements are correct here so whenever
i'm running this test with this test
script is going to pass
now say as an example say this
particular element which is my password
element say this id
changes so now deliberately what i'm
going to do i'm just going to give a
wrong
id here so if i give a wrong id and if i
execute a test script now it is going to
throw an exception at this point
so let's do that so it's going to throw
an exception but now since i want to use
the pause and exception feature what i
do is
it's available here it says pause and
exception by default it is switched off
so when you select this
that means this has been switched on and
now if i execute the script this is
going to
come into a debug mode at this point
where my exception is going to be
through so let's see that so now i have
this i have changed this id to a wrong
id so i'll just say go and
run this current test so let's see how
it operates so let me just bring this
side by side so you can see here
it has entered the email and if you look
here in the console
it is saying trying to find the id for
which i have given
pa and 4s which is a wrong id so it will
look
for some time whether it can find an
element with this particular id
so let's wait for it to throw the
exception there we go so now
it tried enough and actually that step
has failed and there is an exception
saying that that particular web element
is not found
however my test case or the test script
did not exit it has come and paused and
it has entered into a debug mode here
paused and debug now as a tester or an
automation script writer what i can do
here is i can simply go and
correct this now i know this is my
correct id
once i correct this i can execute the
rest of the script right from this point
so now i have this option here if you go
here it says resume test execution so
i'm just going to click on that so it is
going to go ahead
and enter everything yes if you see here
i entered email password and in this
test script what i'm doing is i'm
entering my
first name and my surname instead of
clicking on the login button so it went
ahead and if you look here it says fb
test completed successfully
this is how the pause and exception
feature helps us question 28
how to login into any website if it is
showing an authentication pop-up for
username and password which will be
something like this so this is a typical
authentication pop-up
which you normally see when you are
dealing with some web application
right and to handle them we use
something called as an
alert class and alert class comes with a
method called authenticate using
basically by using this method what we
are trying to do is it helps us skip the
basic
http authentication box so how do we
handle it it is handled exactly the way
we handle any kind of alert box and
selenium
now in this example first what we need
to do is we need to create a weight
object using an explicit weight
now this weight is for what it is for
the alert to pop up
so we basically wait until that
authentication alert pops up and set the
conditions in this explicit way
for as alert is present so that means
you're going to wait
until your authentication pop-up is seen
on your screen
and then once you have that
authentication popup
which is on your screen that is when you
need to go and handle it now to handle
it
for your alert class you're going to
call a method as i said using
authenticate using
and to this you pass a parameter now
this parameter
has to be your username and password
however the way the parameters are
passed here is using
a class object called user and password
now this user and password class it is a
part of selenium security package
all right and this is implemented from
an interface called credentials
so you create this object of class user
and password
using the authentication information
which you have and then pass this as
parameter
to your method called authenticate using
and this way you can handle your
authentication
pop-up question 29 what is the
difference between
single and double slash in x-path a very
important question and
it's a very important thing for each of
you to understand single slash
is used to create an x-path with
absolute path
that is the x path would be created
right from the starting node and the
starting node is
slash html and the double slash is
created
or it's a x path with relative path now
relative path this x path would be
created
uh using any starting location or
anywhere within the document
for example i could start with a div tag
wherein
if i mention double slash ender so this
is going to be treated as a relative
path
and whatever conditions i am going to
give it is going to try and match those
attributes with the stack
right this is called as a relative path
so why don't we just go and take a look
at how do we identify an element
using a relative as well as an absolute
path so if i go back to the same
application
of the facebook this is my facebook
application now i have this crow path
installed which helps me in
identifying x parts of an element now
say i want to
try and see what is the x path of my
element
first name so in the inspector tool i
can see that it has a tag
input and it has a long class name and
it has multiple attributes
which i can use to identify this element
so if i go to my crow path
and again try to match this element so
if i just hover my mouse here
now here you can see this scroll path
gives me both the path one is the
relative x path and one is the absolute
x path now look at the big difference
between these two now relative path was
as simple as
using a slash slash input which is the
tag and an attribute called id
we are able to identify this particular
element same thing if you want to use an
absolute path
and you if you see here it will start
right from the slash
html which is your starting node of your
html page and then it travels down
looking into each of the parent and
child under this until it found this
element
input right so this is absolute path so
you can use either of these paths to
identify
your elements question 30 how do you
find broken links in selenium
webdriver now http is designed for what
to enable communications between your
clients and servers
and if you know there are few commands
like get put post
now get is used to request data from a
specified resource
put command is used to send data over
your server
and post is used to send data to the
server right
now while using these links and trying
to figure out if the link is valid or
not
what you can do is you can use something
called as head requests
now what are head request head requests
are nothing but they are something like
a get request
but they do not have a response body and
usually this is used for checking that
what a get request can return before
actually making a get request
like say before downloading a large file
you would send a head
request before sending the complete get
just to know whether the link
which is provided for downloading a
large file is a genuine link or not
and then looking at the response code is
what you decide that
so how do we do this programmatically
now selenium provides something called
as
http url connection class which has some
methods
to send http request and to capture the
http response codes like the ones which
you see it on the screen
so if we have to see how do we do that
now first thing the logic behind how do
we get this broken links is you get all
the urls on your website first
after getting all the urls now how do
you get the urls by using the tag a
like it is done here so once you get the
complete list of all urls you also check
for a non well a non null or a blank
ones
that is one kind of a check which you
can put after that you create an http
connection object with each of the url
and you open the connection of the url
and you send the request
now this request whatever you're going
to send you are going to send the header
request
to just to get the head and not the
complete get request
now only thing what you're interested in
getting a response code
so once you get the response code what
you have to do is you have to check the
response code against
all your response code now typically
when you're checking for your response
code any response code above 400 is
treated as a client error rest all the
links below 400
are all the valid links so here if you
see 404
you have a response call as link not
found 400 is a bad request 401 is
unauthorized
so you can do a simple check there where
it says if your response code is
above 500 then that particular link has
an error and that is probably going to
be your invalid link so let's
see that in action as how exactly the
code is going to look and how do we
achieve that
now i have a test case written here
called broken links.java
now here what i'm doing is i'm logging
into facebook.com
and then i'm fetching all the elements
with the tag a
now when i say i'm fetching all the
elements with the tag that means i'm
going to get
all the href element from the page and
once i get that
using a for loop i'm going to inspect
each and every
url what i'm going to fetch as i said my
first
check would be to see if it is a null or
is it an empty if i find an empty or a
null value in the url i am just going to
ignore that
and continue the loop and this is where
i actually do the connection with my url
so i create an http url connection
with the url which i have picked it up
from my website then i do this
i send a request here the head request
to get a response code
so once i get this response code is what
i put a if-else statement
and check if my response code is greater
than or equal to 400. so if i find that
if my response code is more than 400
that means this particular url link is
broken and that is how i identify
so once you identify a particular url
which is broken
you can make use of that information
share it with your developers and get it
fixed
so let's go ahead and execute this so in
this test case basically what i'm going
to do is i'm just printing out
all the urls and i'm printing the ones
which are valid and ones which are
broken
since it's a facebook.com website i do
not have any broken url
but this is just a logic of how do we
find a broken url so if you look here
a lot of websites which is getting
listed which says is a valid link so
that means it is getting a response code
which is more than
500 so this is what we saw in the demo
as how do i i trade after i select
all the links on the page and then how
do i determine whether it's a
valid link or it's a broken link all
right so that brings us to the end of
this
interview questions i hope this should
help you and
help you to get through any of the
interviews which you're going to attend
and
also this acts as a pretty good
information set for you so thank you
very much for viewing this video
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here